[Music]
our next speaker comes to us from our
studio
here to talk to us about rm please join
me in welcoming kevin ushay
where's my adapter here where's the
hdmi where's the usb okay
now i'm seeing what we're seeing okay
sorry about that all right
welcome thank you for coming to to my
talk
my name is kevin euche and today i'm
here to talk about
rn so before i talk about rn first i
want to talk about the motivation and
the problem that we're trying to solve
so have you ever finished a project come
back
say a year later and asked
why is my dplyr pipeline suddenly
throwing an error i swear it worked
before
what happened to my ggplot2 plots why
are the bars upside
down i i swear that worked before
okay i re-ran my analysis but now nlme
is complaining about model convergence
i i swear that worked before and so
my goal in rn is how can we make sure
that this
doesn't happen again
now before we talk about our end i want
to talk about pack rat so first
can i get a quick show of hands who has
heard of or used packrat
okay that is wonderful
so what is pac rat and i'm going to
borrow a quote from douglas adams the
story so far
in the beginning pack rat was created
this has made a lot of people very angry
and been widely regarded as a bad move
this is kind of tongue-in-cheek in that
you know you can have success with pack
rat but
it is not a pit of success
it works but for the average user and
especially if your new r
user if you tried using it you probably
ran into a roadblock it probably fell
over on its face
and even if you're an advanced r user
when things go south
it's very challenging to figure out how
to get yourself out of that hole
so rm's goal ultimately is to be a
better pack rat
so first what is rnvit and here is the
sort of
sales pitch of what rnv is it's a
toolkit used to manage
project local libraries of our packages
so you can use your rm to make your
projects more
isolated i said in that every project
gets its own
library of our packages because each
project
has its own library you don't have to
worry about updating packages in that
library potentially breaking
your other projects it'll help you make
your projects a bit more reproducible or
portable
because it captures the state of your r
library and the packages installed in
that library
it captures those into a lock file and
that lock file is kind of like
a shopping list of the packages used in
your project
and rm knows how to use that thing to
recreate your library
in the future and that ties into the
reproducibility story you use snapshot
to create that log file
and later use restore to restore your
library and so if you've used packrat
the api is pretty much the same here
now rm tries to prescribe a default
workflow that
just works for the average user but
remains flexible enough
that alternate workflows can still be
built on top of rmd
and so one of the hardest things for me
in building our end
is just everyone has a different
idea in how projects should be managed
how dependencies should be managed
and ultimately rn has to take an
opinionated take on
how to approach this problem that should
at least work for the average user
but still i wanted rn as opposed to
packer to be flexible enough that if you
don't agree with the way that rm does
things
you can still build your own workflow on
top of it
okay and so before we talk about rn i
just want to give a lay of the land of
what it looks like when you're working
on a project without
rn all right so you've started a new
project
you're ready to use dplyr to analyze
some data and so you're going to load
and use in your project you're calling
library dplyr
and so what happens when we actually run
this code
r is going to search your library paths
for a package called dplyr that you've
installed and then it's going to load it
so the natural questions that arise from
that are what is
a library path what are the active
library paths
and how does r search those library
paths when loading a package
all right so let's explore this quickly
so first a raise of hands who thinks
they can tell me what a
library is you don't have to tell me but
just if you think you know what it is
okay fewer hands than i saw for pac grad
which is surprising
but i'm happy to say that the definition
is quite
simple here it is simply a directory
it's a directory in which
packages get installed
nothing more nothing less let any
remaining mystique
be dispelled it's just a directory it's
a folder on your system
it's where packages go to live and get
loaded
all right now where a bit of the extra
complexity comes in is that each r
session can be configured with multiple
library paths that is a bunch of folders
where r will search
for your installed packages the and you
might have seen the dot libpaths
function which is used to
find those library paths so for example
on my system
i've got two of these the first one
you've got
a library path that's in this library
folder and then the other one which is
actually
associated with my r installation
and just to give some terminology for
these libraries
the first one you see is most often
called the user library because it's
your library it's where the packages
that you download
and install go
the last one you have in that list is
the system library
and that's most typically where the
packages that come with r
are installed
and if you're on linux you might see
another set of libraries which are often
called
site libraries and these you can think
of these as the library paths that your
administrator might take care of for you
so if you're in some organization
your our administrator might want to
install some set of packages in the site
libraries
that would then be available to all
users on the system
all right and then next so when r wants
to load
a package how does it search these
things to find it
all right and so what happens is the
first
installation of the package that is
discovered and loaded no size say the
first
so if you've ever say run into a
situation where you have multiple copies
of a package installed say one in your
user library one in your system library
the first one that it finds the one in
your losing your
user library is the one that gets loaded
but if you've ever thought like
wait which where is this package
actually coming from
you can use the find out package to ask
are hey where where is this package that
i want to use where does it actually
live
and so for me d plier i've made sure to
install in my user library
now i should say if you're on mac os you
can actually install
crayon packages directly into your
system library
which i would argue is not a great idea
because
you want to have this separation of
packages that belong to you
that you've installed versus packages
that belong to your r installation
and so mixing them up can cause some
surprises
but this is worth just knowing and
understanding so you just have a
intuition about what happens when a
package is loaded
all right so what is the challenge here
so by default each r
session is going to use the same set of
library paths
so you've got this library it's really
multiple libraries a set of library
paths
and all the projects on your system
unless you're already managing your
library paths in some way
are going to go and use those same
library paths what does that mean
it means that say if you had d plier
0.8.2
in that library that's the package that
you're using in
every one of your projects but of course
different projects can have different
package dependencies
for example suppose project one may be
something you're working on a while ago
that uses d pliers 0.7.8 and that's
say an older version you got everything
tidy wrapped up maybe it's associated
with the paper that you published
and you're thinking okay i'm done with
this it works i don't want to change it
project two on the other hand you're
using some more uh more
modern version of package you've
upgraded to dplyr0.8.2
and say if you're a developer maybe
you're even using the development
version of dplyr in another project
unfortunately in the current state of
the world these projects all share
the same library path so if you were to
install one of these packages you're
changing the version of dplyr that's
used in all three of those projects so
in this world if you were trying to
switch between projects you'd have to go
back and say okay wait i need to go back
and install deployer 0.7.8 for project
one
oh wait but now i need to reinstall
0.8.2 for project two
and you as you can imagine this could
spell disaster
especially if you had no record of which
version of deep plier or its
dependencies
which there are many were used in a
particular project
so the solution at least the solution
posed by rn
is to ensure that each project gets its
own unique library of packages
by using project local libraries you can
rest assured that upgrading packages in
one project will not risk breaking your
other projects
and so as from this idea the use of
project local libraries that the rn
package is born
we give each project its project local
library we make it simple and
straightforward for
our sessions to use that local library
we provide tools for managing the our
installation
or the r packages installed in those
project local libraries
and we try to make that experience as
seamless as possible so
you can use rn without necessarily being
an expert
on rn
okay and so if you've seen packrat this
will feel familiar
once again the api is quite similar but
i'll walk through it
the first step in activating rn for a
project is just calling
rn init and one thing that it does that
is different from packrat is it actually
forks the state
of your current world of our libraries
into a project local library so the idea
is
you're working on a project you have it
working say you haven't
adopted rm as your default workflow or
you don't manage your library pass in a
specific specific way
but you're saying okay the state of the
world is good right now
i want to capture that in this project
so what you want to call is you call
rnvnit
and it takes the packages you have
installed in that library
and moves them into the project library
so it's like forking that state
into your project and so it'll now be
preserved in that project
independently of your user libraries
the other thing is uh infrastructure
related is we create a project local
dot r profile and that basically makes
sure that every time you start r
in that session rn automatically make
sure you use that project library so you
don't have to worry about managing your
library paths rmv does it for you
automatically when you launch r
and this smears what i said before
around
making sure that after you call r invent
you can work exactly the same you were
as you were before with the only
difference being now you have your own
project local library
there are two main differences you'll
see after you call rn
initna project the first you'll see a
nice little banner printed saying like
okay arm has activated this project for
you and this is the version of rm that
it's using
and the second thing is as i've said the
library pass will now be changed
and so these slides are actually using
rn for
its own library and dependence map
dependency management
and so you've got here this giant
library path that lives in the folder
for this project and also this
sandbox library as i'll call it which
we'll talk about later if we have time
but this is basically like a safe
version of your
system library okay
so that is the first goal making it easy
to use project local libraries
the second goal is to make it easy to
save and load the state of those
libraries
or in the parlance of rns snapshot
to save the state of a library and
restore to
reinstall those packages into a library
you can capture the state of your
project library using snapshot
and so when you call snapshot it'll give
you a little
log of what's changing of what is
what dependencies it's capturing when
you
call snapshot so in this case i'm just
capturing three packages for a project
let's say
and it's capturing from crayon the r
markdown packages
or the markdown package the arm markdown
package and the yaml package
and this star is just as a placeholder
to say we didn't know about this before
now we know that using version 1.1 of
markdown now using
2.1 of the r markdown package 2.2.0 of
the yaml package
and i say do you want to proceed yes
please write those and it writes it to
this thing we call the lock file so
we're serializing the state of your
project library to a file called a lock
file which
we'll name on the file system as rm.lock
so this thing is just a text file it's
a shopping list it's the packages that
you had installed
in your library their versions and where
they came from
so a quick look at what that looks like
it's the json file
you can see i've printed a single
package record here for rns
we've got rn version 0.9.2 and in this
case it came from cram
all right so why do we want these lock
files
there's three cases that i that i
outlined specifically here one is for
time capsules this is the case where
you've
okay i'm done a project i want to make
sure that this project still runs a year
from now
to do that i want to make sure i know
what packages i have and i want to make
sure those packages
exist over time so i can revisit later
for collaborative workflows if you're
working with
a set of collaborators you want to
probably make sure everyone is working
with the same environment
if people have different computer
machines one way to make sure you
synchronize the environment is
share the lock file have everyone
restore from that lock file and that way
you're sure everyone's using the same
set of r packages
and also for deployment so if you're
working on something locally
and it works on your machine you might
use rm to make
give yourself some extra guarantees that
it works on the machine you're deploying
on by
replicating your library on that other
machine
okay so given a lock file you create
your lock file with snapshot
and you restore the state of your
library later with restore
and so restore will give you a very
similar kind of output it will tell you
what packages are going to be installed
how they differ from the package that
was already installed if any
and what's the version so in this case
restore is installing a brand new
version of the
markdown down in yaml packages and then
when it goes it'll give you a little log
of how these packages were installed in
this case
this case they're actually linked from
something called the orange cache we'll
talk about that in a bit but it's just a
way to speed up
package installation
okay and fortunately rm is able to
restore from a number of sources if
you've used remotes or dev tools it
basically understands
all those same sources cran bioconductor
github gitlab bitbucket
if you have another remote source that
you'd like rmf to support you can
let me know on the github issue tracker
and we can see if that can become a
possibility
another big thing is i've made an effort
to ensure that you can authenticate with
private repositories so if you have your
own say cram-like repository hidden
behind
some kind of authentication mechanism rn
has some tools to make it easier to
authenticate
all right so these are the three main
features of our end
i think these are the three things you
need to know if you want to get started
the rest of talk will be kind of extra
on top of that
but in it to initialize your project
give yourself a project local library
snapshot to save the state of your
library once you
are ready to save the state and restore
if you need to restore
your project library from a previously
generated lock file
okay and so one major issue
with project local libraries is the
duplication
of identical packages across projects
and so if you've used packrat before
you've probably seen this issue
before so if you had 10 projects that
use d plyer 0.9.2
then you have 10 project libraries that
also have deep pliers 0.9.2 installed
and this can be costly both in terms of
disk space use
and installation time especially if say
you're on a linux machine you're
installing these things from sources
so imagine having to install the tidy
verse every time you start a new project
and so this is what i got from running
it on my
linux vm it took uh
just over six or seven minutes which is
too long when you
when you want to get started on
something you know when you're
starting a new project you want to just
get going you don't want to spend 10
minutes just to get
up and running so the way rn
solves this problem is with the global
cache and what this basically is is a
giant
bucket of all the packages you have
installed
and in each of your project libraries
rather than having
the actual installation of that package
it's a link
into that cache so the idea is that
rather than having 10 installations of d
pliers 0.9.2
you install that package once you put in
the cache
and then rm knows how to pull that out
whenever it needs to
all right i have unfortunately just one
more minute
so i want to just demonstrate quickly
why i am so excited about rn versus
packrat
so i have this
simple project that uses the tidyverse
we're going to call it packrat project
and we're going to call packrat init
and so this is the kind of experience
you might have had initially using
packrat and already it's complaining
about
our studio api because i have a
development version that doesn't know
how to get from crayon
seems to be kind of sitting and waiting
we don't quite know what's going on
it's warning again
just like imagine you're excited to get
started on a project and oh
wait so now we have to go do all this
stuff
okay so packrat is busy
let's go to our rn project which has the
same
library tidy verse in a file and let's
initialize it and let's see what happens
initializing project discovering
packages giant list of packages
we've written your log file okay you're
done you're ready to go now you can
start working with rn
okay i'm sorry that i put too many
slides i can fit in this talk but i will
put this online
so i'm going to put if you want to see
these later you can go the link here
you